c'est une petite boutique au cette route
de trouville voilà vingt ans maintenant
que la chiffo s'inscrit en toutes
lettres dans le tissu social canet cette
structure en quoi jusqu'à cinquante et
une personnes en contrat à durée
déterminée d'insertion
encadrés par six salariés permanents
vous êtes au coeur de l'atelier
d'insertion socioprofessionnelle nous
sommes au coeur de la machine scifo
l'atelier technique équipes du matin et
de l'après-midi et pas moins de douze
employés ils sont affairés aux bons
soins du tissu des centaines de sacs
peser livrer tout de suite après la
collecte
ici chaque personne traite environ 300
kg de vêtements par jour en a quatre
personnes au tri des vêtements par
rapport à la fraîcheur et l état d'usure
si le vêtement est conservée il est
visité à l'endroit à l'envers et ensuite
il est orienté dans différents bacs les
tendances les classiques les marques et
on appelle aussi des coups de coeur
les vêtements qui seront gommés qui
rentrent pas dans les trois critères
derrière l'impératif de production pour
achalander le magasin se cachent des
critères de sélection très stricte
plus de 80% des vêtements collectés sont
ainsi envoyés au recyclage
ce qui sont soit trop abîmés soit ils
ont des tâches soient soit ils sont
mauvais tout simplement parce qu'on
trouve un peu de tout dans les sacs
qu'on nous apporte est donc là on va les
renvoyer à koba nord tritex ces articles
sont ainsi revendu à la tonne à cette
association
l'opération permet ainsi à la chiffo
d'assurer une partie de son
autofinancement
selon la saison certains vêtements
seront stockés avant d'être vendus les
jours de braderie power magasin en tout
on estime que seulement 15 à 17 % de la
collecte se retrouvent sur cintres dans
la boutique 120 mètres carrés de surface
de vente du vêtement bien sûr mais aussi
de la chaussures des accessoires ou bien
encore du mobilier pour une pratique de
prix on peut plus solidaire on a à peu
près 70 à 80 passages en caisse par jour
on arrive de plus en plus à se faire
connaître au niveau au niveau de caen et
son agglomération et à les gens qui
viennent aussi des alentours
je préfère venir dans dés ce type de
magasin où je sais que je vais pouvoir
réaliser quelque chose de vraiment
important pour ceux qui émettent du
caire que
la dalle est dépensé une fortune juste
pour complètement dans un autre magasin
de marque au fil du temps ce lieu donc
devenu une véritable vitrine
d'exposition pour l'atelier d'insertion
cette boutique elle a une double
finalité être un outil d'insertion mais
également être notre source de revenu
c'est aussi la façade extérieure
et puis c'est le lieux que fréquentent
les donateurs la chiffo n'existerait pas
on ne tirait pas textile si nous
n'avions pas tous les donateurs qui
viennent apporter leurs vêtements et
leurs objets dont ils n'ont plus
l'utilité des donateurs en passant par
les salariés et les fidèles clients de
la chiffo cette boutique solidaire a
décidément tout pour faire les affaires
de tout le monde